gee thank you so I think I can use the
opportunity almost the last speaker to
say that I'm that you I and I'm sure
many of us are enjoying this workshop
really really a lot so thank you
organizers it's great to like meet
everybody together and hear about all
the progress so I will be so in the
spirit as I said yesterday in the spirit
of the conjectures need to keep flowing
that's the spirit of this talk so it's
about the work that I have done with
flora and mark and two members of the
Japanese school that like use replicas
and cavity metals and provide you know
cool conjectures to be proven daisuke
kobashi mind his postdoc ayaka Tsikata
so about about a work that we did couple
years back and at first see somehow
motivated it one way but in this talk i
will show you somehow since we were
thinking about couple of problems
actually found maybe like a more
interesting way to motivate that problem
so that's how i start then i will talk
about the problem how we solved it and
some like results so what is feature
learning so this is just like one slide
that one can see today you know in
number of blogs and Facebook and all
over the place even if you don't follow
what's happening in machine learning you
can't escape it so what does it mean
feature learning so presented some data
in this case this would be some database
of faces and then when the wood machine
learning tries to do is to try it tries
to find the here are Co features so it
first realizes that it's useful to think
of the faces no linear combination of
some kind of edges of wavelets like in
this picture and then in the second
level if you make linear combinations of
those you get little like I or nose etc
feature like that and then you get like
some proto faces that then serve to do
some classification face recognition so
this is like a very hand baby thing now
how this how is this done mathematically
so the prototypical model how is this
done mathematically would be this
move the layer feed-forward perceptron
so that's that that goes back to works
more than 50 years ago so what are the
things here so your data would be this
matrix Y so you have P samples of on so
you have P images of each of them has n
pixels also that's what you may think
about if you want and then for each of
the images you have some labels you say
it's person a or base person beer it's a
woman or it's a man say that you want to
recognize women from men in the fears so
what you do you present your pictures
the bits the variables to the first
layer of the network and then this this
arrow smeared means that you multiply
them by some matrix f1 which is
representing the first layer of the
features so this so these arrows that
are coming forced us to this point that
would be one of these like wavelet one
of these like edges little somewhere
this would be another one this would be
another one and then this matrix F 2
corresponds to the second level of the
feature so this would be say like I and
this would be the nose and then this
third layer of of the neural network
would correspond to know is this a man
or is it a woman something very roughly
and what what what people got very good
at in the past say 10 years is that we
have really good algorithms to actually
given the data and given the labels so
that's the things that you know we learn
the hero of the features f1 f2 f3 etc
such that you know the corresponding
function so so we do y times f1 and then
there is some activation function like
the word what this variable here is some
function usually some sigmoid or some
like other function so this would be
these functions G 1 2 3 etc and so
that's what people are very good at now
this is about supervised learning when
you have some labels so now in many
situations you either don't have many
labeled data or the labels are bad or
you say you know the ultimate goal of
machine learning is to do an supervised
learning so no labels just data and find
the features just from the data so there
is a little twist on this multi-layer
perceptron which is called auto encoder
and again it's it's a set of ideas that
goes long time back it's very related
except you don't have the labels you
still have your data the same thing so
the beginning is the Saviour try to
decompose your data into features but
then you don't know you know what you
don't have any labels so what you do you
somehow copy you make a mirror image
like this these functions here would be
a little different but otherwise is
basically a mirror image of your network
and at the end you also put the data so
what you're trying to do you're trying
to learn features and somehow compress
your image in such a way that if you
somehow do something related on the
other side that you reconstruct your
image back so you can also think about
this as a kind of a compression right
the middle layer here that would be like
a compressed version of your features of
your data it's able just by using the
features to reconstruct your data back
so this the outdoor encoder so again you
learn so here I put it in a way that the
f1 is exactly the same as the f1 here so
there's the tight ways this can be
relaxed and you can do all so different
there are many many variants of this out
to encode so of a fine that's still is
so that's interesting so we would like
to analyze something like that but when
you are thinking about it we somehow yo
we ended up realizing that basically
having like the copy here and copy yours
hey that's that's what it's done because
for this architecture we have the
algorithms but if we like want to think
about it theoretically maybe we can just
forget about the right hand side and
just think about about the left hand
side and just think about the right hand
side and okay maybe it has some other
name in literature but you're thinking
along these lines with Ricardo and flora
landmark and and callow and we call this
like for ourselves inverts wrong so what
is this so this is again the data and
you try to take on post
data into features and some matrix F
which is like the compressed version of
your data such that this is equal to the
data right and now we would like to get
some algorithms and understand like when
is this possible how little this layer
can be etc but in order to build a
theory for something like that yes a
question so you're saying you want a
generative model with a small number
input variables which produces a
distribution about this which looks like
your data set yeah which is exactly my
data set is as close to my data set as
possible so so how do you think about
the fury right that like so I so ideally
you would like the data to be some real
data like these faces that the base of
images or something like that so with
the kind of techniques that we like have
and we were hearing about in this talk I
mean if we want that then we cannot do
much I mean okay but why do I fight I
mean I can maybe do some algorithms but
if I want some theory I cannot do much
so what is some case where I could do
something so say that why the data were
random iid so some matrix with random
iid element so okay that's a good case
for like our kind of methodology like
the replica method cavity method and
indeed for yet simpler version of this
of this case if I knew these mattresses
f1 and f2 then this is basically one
this is basically perceptron and there
has been a long line of works in the 80s
and 90s with with replicas and cavity
method solving note saying things about
a ball neural networks but oh ok random
data but random data do not have
features so if you want to learn
something about feature learning and we
use random data then ok yeah somehow
duped right what can be done like if you
don't have so this we are not happy
either so what about what about creating
data but by planting in some features so
in this dope you heard a lot about like
interference problems planted problems
so what what about doing that what about
like starting with some extra
our f1 star and f2 star that creates the
data and then we forget the star
matrices and we want to reconstruct them
back so that would be the planted
inverter the data are still you are a
random there and now elements of this
would be I ID so we are still in the
framework where these kind of metals can
be applied but we are also in a
framework where we you know we planted
in arundel features but at least we can
meaningfully ask the questions can we
find the features back and we at least
know what the features are so so that's
that somehow the strategy okay and now
now I'm getting to the to the form of
this problem that I will actually talk
about in this talk and that's the
absolutely same place non trivial case
where I only have one layer here so why
was the previous two slides ago I had
two layers so here I really have only
one leg so what am i doing these are the
data and I'm trying to find F and X such
that the product of f NX and activation
function on it this can be some little
noisy some arbitrary element vice
function reproduces well the data so and
set like that this is actually a no
problem that is known out of neural
network setting that's sometimes it's
often is called diction alerting often
it's called sparse coding and setting up
this problem and thinking of some
algorithms to solve it goes back to
works again 20 20 years ago or matrix
factorization I like its it I like to
call it like matrix factorization
because that's what it really is okay
so now okay matrix factorization so that
was the motivation so if you like think
okay this is a relevant or I didn't
understand okay start let's start again
I could because the talk would have
started here okay the previous part was
just like auxiliary so what am i oh ok i
motivated this problem as a smallest not
evil piece of feature learning but you
can forget about that and just so what
we are doing here is that we want to
represent p samples of n dimensional
data that we know by some features f
that we don't know and some weights acts
that we don't know through some
activation function f which you know in
the examples i will be showing about
this will just be additive Gaussian
noise to the product of F times X but
you can think of sigmoid you can think
of some like whatever function that is
like not completely crazy and and and so
the way to motivate you know maybe like
the way I like to explain what's diction
allure nning is like think of think of
that you are that you have some
sequences of sound so how should you
represent sequences of sound ok so in
acoustics people worked for 20 years and
you know noticed among others and worked
hard at like representing it in free
transform if you just free our transform
sound you get some representation that
is sparse right and free a sound appears
like just few peaks and this is very
useful because this is like very
compressed as far as then you can do
many things on it ok in images in image
processing people did the same thing and
worked out wavelets right now if I give
you like a generic data set what is the
representation in which this data set
can be written as sparse or as much like
a much lower dimension we don't know and
that's what this problem is about right
so ideally without knowing anything if
why was sounds this dictionary you
should learn that good f is a furrier
transform and X is parsed so that
somehow the idea but here we are you're
not thinking about some real data as we
are really we will be set there working
in this planted case where everything is
just like random bits and this problem
is related to
talks that we had earlier this week the
one by Florence akela who talked about
lowering matrix factorization so this
would be also matrix factorization but
the art that I will be treating here is
will be big for us in his talk it was
constant and it's also related to the
dog by David store who talked about
tensor factorizations so if i had had x
here at x transpose and if i added a
third one here that would be exactly the
case about which david work so this is
just the matrix version of of that ok so
diction learning is a problem that l
since 20 years is studied so here i just
like copy pasted the the corresponding
you know references from our article i'm
not saying this is exhausting there are
really many works so both on the
algorithmic size there are really many
algorithms that somehow do reasonably
well with which you can like in many
applications achieve something really
interesting the the thing is that they
are somehow all work like the number of
the number of samples that all these
algorithms needs is very very big so
this is about coming to the neural
networks like neural networks today to
learn something they need many many many
of these labels sub day is a samples so
one of the first questions we asked like
what some of the minimal number of
samples you need such that the
information is still there and such that
it is algorithmically tractable so does
that feel like a theoretically maybe the
first question that one asks then there
is also theory where people study the
study the central complexity etc so this
would be more like like classical
statistical papers many of them they
would assume some incoherence of rows of
the of the atoms in the dictionary and
sparsity of x and they would be proving
things under quad generic conditions but
when this but they mostly work when the
sparsity of s is very big like the only
few elements in the X that are nonzero
so maybe four mins number of
applications when the sparsity is not so
small made to the relevant ratio so not
much is so all that is known for that
regime is like not very good like you
need and more game time some big
constant of samples like the bounds
that are existing are not very good and
something like the mmse s in somebody
and settings are not so these are the
things that we can do so once again the
setting we have this matrix
factorization and the teacher crease
this X star F F star and generates the
data and then the student knows the data
knows the distributions PX and PF but
doesn't know the XR + f star and tries
to reconstruct it and all right so how
to solve this so if you have a student
that followed well for some light
bayesian statistics undergraduate
lecture and the student will know that
the optimal way of solving this is to
build the posterior for this problem so
posterior so what is the probability of
X and I've given Y well you need to put
your prior on FN put your prior on X
here and put the likelihood of
generating your data if F and X was what
you assume it was ok and the optimal way
then to estimate X and F that will be in
the mean square error closest to the
true one is to take marginal
probabilities of this posterior and take
the means of this marginal posteriors
that's the bias optimal estimate
decipher page 30 of some bias adherence
book so we know what to do in principle
was the best way well of course the
trouble is that this is not tractable so
let's see you know what can be done if
we need to stick to a retractable
algorithm but also what is the
performance of this bias optimal thing
if we actually could do it so these are
the two basic questions that we have
here so to compute the mmsc which would
be the mean square error of the bias of
the molesta mater and then the MSC which
is the best algorithmically achievable
bar ok so it cannot be done in general
but in this setting where we generated
the data with some like plant with
random FNX we can solve this problem
with replicas we can compute this
performance both the best bias optimal
performance and the best algorithmic
performance with
the via the replica method so how is
that working well that's basically
computing the Z of just put the
normalization of this posterior in some
limit so the limit is kind of so that
somehow the interesting thing here
because it also distinguishes from the
existing works mission which made you
worked with the different limits so so
the limit we are working so the
dimensions of these matrices which are
like the f is P times N and the exes p
times R times n and the f is P times are
they are all of the same order they all
go to infinity but if i divide one by
another it's a constant okay so I have
these two constant the Alpha NP and then
the the elements of these matrices so we
choose it in a way that vice order that
elements of Y and X are 0 for 1 but
since I'm multiply order n terms of X
with order n terms of F then F needs to
scale differently and that's how we
choose it and we have one more condition
is for the for death for the
computations to go through we need the
mean of the F to be 0 the ok so that's
so that's somehow a restriction on what
the PFF needs to be so all I'm saying
will be working only if the distribution
of F has your own and then how does the
replica method work so that's the usual
think I mean you know finite fraction of
people that can do that casual that
death calculation casually sitting on
the room where is a co-author of this
paper so it's it's a standard thing
although it's some work so what we do is
that ok we want to average we want to
get a typical value of this
normalization because then from this by
dairy vaiting it with respect to various
parameters we can compute like things
like the margins and the news fairer and
things like so we know that this little
identity is true and we also noticed
that if animals in teacher then
computing this average is not dead hard
and then we pretend that the the same
expression holds also when n is
building teacher and send n 20 and get
some expression so after we do that we
end up with their with with a form that
looks like this like the what we want
will be integral over three parameters
so they sound like real valued numbers
between zero and one of of some
exponential with where there is N
squared so something very big time some
function so we'll see this integral will
be dominated by the place where this
function is maximum okay so now how this
function looks like so that's the
expression for this function in this
problem okay so okay maybe it's not so
easy to parse but if I eat out that it's
actually not so it's it's kind of simple
because the first line of this
expression depends only on this output
probability oh it's some integral of
some stuff where the parameters appear
the other variables that you see there
that's basically only the integration
variables there is this alpha and P
which were the ratios the dimensions of
our problem the second line is only
related to the distribution of the of
the dictionary F and the third line is
only related to the distribution of
these ways so somehow the three the
three things that determined our problem
they are all decoupled here and moreover
when you think like one more minute
about it you have like all this horrible
integral here it's actually not so
horrible that's like if you had like
scholar denoising problem and you want
it to compute the mutual information of
a scholar de-noising problem so that's
something like easy to do not high
dimensional just color that's the mutual
information that you would get Gabe it
somewhere where the app where the
parameters like em hat which would
somehow we be relate this to the noise
in the tenderizing problem so the form
this equation takes is not like it's
quite natural I mean once you somehow
get familiar to it and okay so I said
that we need to find maximum of that and
then the global maximum of that is then
directly related to the best error this
bias optimal procedure would do an
estimation
of the of the matrix of the F and X all
right and so then okay it's the global
maximum so then what I would like to
write is the stationary wave
stationarity conditions of for death
energy and okay that's another like
correspondingly yo not easy to parse set
of equations but again I mean this these
are set of three equations that are
somehow decoupled and none of this none
of it here depends on the on the
distribution of the X and F and and the
p.m. so this is very generic and the
only thing that actually depends on what
precisely was your problem are these
like particular functions here so all
you need is basically these integrals of
Goshen's times your priors times your
output Tom how the function that
determines the channel output so ok so
this is like at kneel at the n is quite
an elegant set of equations that like
solve all these problems at once like
for all priors for all outputs like we
can tell with this problem what's
happening in this stock ok so there was
the replica solution now if you when we
asked about algorithms so this is no
this is a problem where somehow
everybody every variable talks to every
variable so Andrea told us on Monday
that in cases like that the good thing
to do is this approximate message
passing so that's what we will do so
this kind offer so let's wrap let's take
the problem that we had but now we
represent it as a factor graph right we
really take this posterior distribution
and write the corresponding factor graph
so this this like it picture that one
draws when one explains what's a narrow
network it's not the factor graph the
factor graph is a little different right
the whys are not variables that are the
checks and the F and X are both
variables and these connections are like
we're you know we're in the posterior
these these variables appear together
with the checks and then the priors are
represented here ok so that's a factor
graph and then no SS game said yesterday
like this is the point where I can like
to switch off the brain and have a
factor graph i have a posterior a
beautification okay so it's a
complicated factor graph it's
complicated belief propagation but okies
straightforward except that this one now
Here I am Here I am making integrals
overall and variables so this will take
X time exponentially an end so writing
belief propagation here sure I can do it
but it's not so useful but at the same
time I realized that by assumptions of
the belief propagation the incoming
messages are independent and they are
many and so it smells like central limit
theorem okay if I have some soft or here
its products but if I take longer if not
that it's sums of many independent terms
so I will be able to treat only its
variant only to keep only the variances
and the means and that's exactly what
happens and if we do that that's what
leads to this approximate message
passing so this is something that we
heard on a bit already in the previous
talks this
well because they all come from why
through why right i mean the posterior
here I mean all all the constraints I
have are related to some way and this Y
is taking some X and is taking some f's
but that's it I mean it's not there like
the Y's are the interactions between F
and X Y is no even why the photograph I
can infer effort without doing anything
because Y is not the variable x is a
constraint it's what you make it's what
I measure but it's a constraint okay
here so from physics point of view this
this is very closely related to the
talus under so polymer equation that you
are very familiar with in the sting
glass literature and for problems that
are formally more related to the prison
problem like the code division multiple
access problem or the perceptron
yoshioka kobashi mine collaborators
basically wrote these equations like 12
years ago down on several papers in
which they didn't quite get them right
but in one of them they got the right
but okay this paper was kind of
forgotten or no not much attention was
put to it so when we when when really a
lot of people started to work on this
approximate message passing that was
after the work of of andrea and and
Maliki and don't know home when they
generalize this approach and to tune on
by Xion cases to continuous variables
and also had a beautiful line of works
where they basically set the firm
rigorous foundations to this equation to
this algorithm and state evolution and
what it all means so after this set of
works you know many people including
including us started to work on
approximate message passing but note
that in the present problem this
approximate message passenger is the
same spirit of an algorithm but it
doesn't quite fit in the setting for
which things are already
like the state evolution etc so it's an
approximate message passing but the not
much is known about this one rigorously
and read somehow concentrate on the on
the phase diagrams and the theory but
there is this beautiful work by phil
schneider parker and sever where they
concentrate on the algorithm and have
some demonstrations on applications some
like video processing and quite some so
if you're interested in that that's the
paper to go to see this is how the
algorithm looks like so that's a another
I before last slide with like horrible
set of equations difficult to parse but
it's it's somehow the same you know it's
very similar to to this simpler form
that Andre was presenting which was just
one equation one has the estimators this
X head and I've had the best of course
la the estimators of the elements of the
matrices that we are looking for and
they are given by by some functions of
some variances which basically I don't
know I wrote them down explicitly but in
the large n limit they converge to some
constants so usually when I if I wanted
to simplify this would just be some like
I wouldn't write them and there will
just be some dependents all of these f
functions and and everything is somehow
coppage twice because I have the
estimators for the X and estimators for
the f so in essence you can only like
look at half of these equations so what
is less they're the really important one
would be an expression like that this T
which is like the fact the mean that is
fed to this function that then estimates
the X and it has the part that is like
the X here then this gets divided by
something and then there are two terms
that are the own soccer terms some of
the structure of these equations is very
close to the structure of of the
equations for compressing say for
instance but they are you know I have
terms where I multiply the two
estimators against each other so this is
somehow what makes a difference it's not
like x a matrix that I know it's one x
the other and this would somehow it
makes it like not straightforward to
apply some of the some of the method has
been done
about it what's nice about it you know
it's like some matrix multiplications so
you can you can code it easily and
everything that depends on the
specificities of the problems are these
like functions that you put like s like
a part in your code that depending the
explicit way of your you know two priors
and of the output distribution so
everything is like modeler and you can
solve many problems at once just by
writing these so then we write the state
evolution for this equation so that's
just to see you know what happens to the
when you run these equations how does
the error evolved for instance so for
that V derive this we define this order
parameters and track their evolution so
that's again some computation and you
end up with a mother's horrible set of
equation but if you paid attention
that's just a repetition of the slide
like six slides ago that was the result
of the replica method so I don't need to
explain them just say the bottom line
right the state evolution of a MP always
gives the exactly same expression as the
replica metal like these two seems quite
different but they are interlinked and
since the 80s like by the work of my
surprise a we know that these are the
you know they lead to the same
predictions so so we have to do they
lead to the same function which if we
look at its global minimum that's the
optimal performance and if you look at
this local met max maximum sorry I said
minimum global maximum and local maximum
with the worst error that's the
performance of the of the inp algorithm
okay so if this function has a unique
optimum maximum then I MPs information
theoretically optimal well if it doesn't
then it is support them so now okay i
can show you some figures of what
happens in some specific cases so now i
specify first time you know i specify
what these like distributions are so I
am factorizing a matrix into a product
of two matrices plus Gaussian noise that
means that this P out is just discussion
and
looking at this f just random IIED
Gaussian and this X I am looking sparse
so I'm trying to find a dictionary such
that the data can be explained with this
dictionary as something sparse and the
sparsity of this x is the row so Roy is
the number of non zeros so the smaller
the road somehow easier it you know the
more information there should be in this
way about what these matrices are and so
this is just okay in that case this
expresses I was writing simplify
something that only has like one
integral so numerically I put it in
MATLAB Oh Mathematica whatever it's not
it's quite easy to plot this function
and look what the maxima oh and this is
the app that for instance the optimal
air that you obtained so what are taxes
here so the way this axis that's the
error so blue it's like very good
performance red is like basically doing
as bad as randomly guessing from the
prior then here is the noise so of
course the bigger the noise the worse it
should be and this axis finally that's
how many samples of the data I presented
/ some of these reference dimensions so
the more data I presented the easier it
should be to recover the dictionary and
you know that the slopes are in the
direction where that we somehow expect
and we see that you have some nice phase
transitions here right there are some
like very sharp jumpsuit so that's
really are always happy when you see
something like that because you can
study it so here is the same picture but
looking from above and comparing to the
mean square error that the algorithm
gives you so you see there is a region
where it's exactly the same but then
there is a region here where it's not
the same where the algorithm is doing
bad but if I you know had infinite
computational power I could do very well
so now let's like just think of the case
without noise like where would this
phase transition be so at least I can
like have some very elementary lower
bound of where the phase transition
can be and that's if I have no noise and
the variables of X and F are continues
okay then basically what needs to be
true that I can recover F and X from Y
is that at least the number of elements
in why should be bigger than the number
of elements I try to recover right
because if it's not then like clearly i
will have some degeneration i will not
be able to recover it so that's what
gives me this simple all our about so
when the parameters i introduce alpha
needs to be bigger penis to be bigger
than alpha divided by alpha minus rho
and if i plot the position of this phase
transition i obtain that the that the
information theoretic transition so when
I you don't pay attention to the
computation complexities exactly at that
point so at least as the prediction of
the replica method so this is saying
that whenever I knew them in the
noiseless case whenever I have more
measurements the number of unknowns then
information theoretically the dictionary
is discoverable so that's like quite a
very simple result but it's very far
away from from the results you know
admittedly this like existing results
they use much weaker conditions on what
the dictionary could be here we really
had it I idea random but you know
showing something like that that for the
dictionary iid random this is actually
the information theoretic transition
that's like one open question that maybe
should not be so hard and then so how
does the algorithmic transition compare
no it's not this at some constant times
this applied small constant when we are
at small density so it's worse but not
so much and again the performance of the
other so there is this like hard face
that we heard about this weaker about
several times that's interesting from
the theoretical point of view but
somehow this lines gives us the
benchmark of how it is in this like
simple random case
how the algorithm should be able to to
do well right and in some other problems
like your first answered about the
stochastic block model we have like the
algorithmic transition and we have
spectral algorithms as DP algorithms
belief propagation Monte Carlo that all
get like very close to it like acid or
very close to it at this this matrix
factorization problem we are not at all
yet they're like all the existing
algorithms dialects I'm are far far
above this line but we should try to get
to it so that's like it's that should be
opening like the work in that direction
like which algorithms in this random
setting would get to this line that's
the question yes that hard face so the
problem remains hard no matter what the
sample complexity is so I give you
infinite amount of deal at the prom
that's a good remark so I should have
said that so that's because even if you
knew the diction if you knew the
dictionary then the problem we are
talking about is linear estimation right
if I have wise F times X and I give you
the dictionary you have sparse linear
estimation X is sparse and so you can
understand this denominator here the
Alpha used to be bigger than row that's
like the number of measurements even if
you knew the dictionary the number of
measurements needs to be bigger than the
sparsity sure because otherwise you
cannot do anything and and there is
another awesome thought that even if you
knew the dictionary algorithmically you
cannot quite get to this alpha equal row
even if you knew the dictionary I that
would be like if you did if you were
doing the l1 minimization that would be
the donor hot an airline and in this
case is the biasing setting so that
would be the line that comes out this
this row as cscs stands for compressed
sensing this is the this is the smallest
density for come for which you put this
you could recover the signal even if you
knew the dictionary so so so the
asymptote of this curve is given by that
you know it's like no matter how sure
like if you had infinitely many samples
you would maybe you know the
best you could do you could discover
exactly the dictionary but then even if
you had the dictionary you wouldn't be
able to say anything about the signal
and so since you are not able to say
anything about the signal you actually
wouldn't be also able to discover the
dictionary the MSC will be very big on
both of them but that's where these
asymptotes comes got some tots comes
from the kind of curve depends on the
algorithm so the blue curve so this blue
curve is for the ANP so now the the
conjecture is you know nothing should do
better than this now if you ask me does
the present algorithm reach it so not
quite there are some like a convergence
problem so this if i take the
implementation the best one that there
is out there so far by h knitter and
parker and sever know there is a bunch
of implementation tricks they slow it
down and you know do some adaptive
damping and quite a number of tricks to
like make it converge on the practical
problems but if you run it on this
random and instances is not quite
reaching this life so even if for the
iamp there is still some work to do to
actually algorithmically match it and
then there is the question what about
all the other builders so yeah none of
it is like even close so the question is
how close can we get on you know is it
even a meaningful line here what's
happening so that's the test the
conclusion so I presented you this
problem which can be thought as the
simple model for future learning if you
want and as such it you know why to
study like a randomly generated data if
all the data that are the world are
certainly not random well the idea is
the same like if with the stochastic
bokmål right it's also a random all and
nothing looks like generated from the
sarcastic bokmål but at least we can do
some theory and compare the existing
algorithmic performance to what should
be possible on that model and that gives
us some understanding so that somehow
the spirit of this work and so what we
derived where the you know the formula
for was the best best error
independently of algorithmic complexity
and was the
conjecture for the best achievable error
with algorithms and the the message here
is that in this particular problem the
state of our algorithms are not close to
it yet so there is definitely work for
space for improvement and if you want to
read about it more this is our paper and
the algorithmic application papers this
one and the final slide is the to-do
list so what you know what what are the
things that somehow seems Within Reach
and probably if you like sit here again
in SE 5-10 years then a lot of it will
be done so on the math site you know
proving that the state evolution for
this like high rank matrix factorization
is actually correct that's that's an
interesting or open problem proving that
the detectability lower bound is tight
in the noiseless planted factorization
might also be achievable we are some
like second moment method like we
haven't done it but it's the type of
problem that that should be that should
be doable hopefully then you know this
question of which algo tarde algorithms
that provably or empirically both are
interesting work down to the phase
transitions that we computed so that's
both for math and computer science then
you know even know usually usually the
belief propagation is the like first
candidate about it that has like good
empirical performance in this case it's
not quite the case so what's really
happening when we try to implement the
inp in this case what suppose was the
problem here still not quite sure the
next question would be liquid like soft
so far I was we were assuming that we
know what were the distributions PX and
PF so what if we don't know that or we
want to find some grout stage etc so you
know doing the replica symmetry breaking
for this for these problems or
generalize to two tensors two more
layers or two priors that are
non-separable that are not like this iid
primers okay these are all directions
that I think are interesting to look at
that's up
questions yeah in the limit is all the
disability of the problem coming from
what you mentioned even if I gave it
basically the other problem is odd or is
there some additional difficulty from
the other side also like not knowing
what is asymptotically the problem just
I know it's both it's both because I
mean I just explained that are simple
but if you knew the dictionary you
couldn't pass it anyway but if you look
how you know a buff if I go back to this
figure like above the blue line if you
look was the MSC that the algorithm is
getting its is bad on both so it's yeah
it's both that you like blue line that
would just that would be this black line
this would be this black line so with no
you would not need any if you knew the
dictionary you know the samples you have
them to be able to learn the dictionary
if you know the dictionary then
basically the problem becomes
independent sample by sample right you
have no the posterior is just the
product over the different samples so
just before one sample you could learn
it up to here
question yeah I'm curious about the
state of actual benchmark datasets in
this area so princess it it seems like I
would have to show you an awful lot of
audio files before in terms of sparsity
was worth describing it in terms of
Fourier functions or wavelets as opposed
to you know saying oh your basis is you
know one for each audio file so I mean
and similarly with images so yeah so
what people do most people do I don't
know so much for some but for images
will people do like first of all you
know these these algorithms like you at
least need to multiply the matrices
though they are n square and they cannot
be better than n square so is there it's
quite slow to start with so people take
like little patches usually they will
take like eight times eight patches from
the images and that would be the samples
so you cannot even with the current
stuff you cannot even like really do
learning on the full images usually they
do learning on the patches and and yeah
but even in the like very in the odds
housing field work in 97 I mean that's
what they did and they and they learn a
dictionary with with their k svt type of
algorithm which no looks like when you
look at it those are the wavelets so
there's somehow okay the high level of
like why their paper was punch line off
of their paper that they could somehow
learn something that looks like the
wavelets from small patches and but yes
you need to present a lot a lot a lot of
them so but I think it's time to ask you
know what's the smallest number of
patches that you need to learn something
and that's simple we try to go
the question
okay I'll race we'll see what 1145 for
the grand finale